[Musique]
daniel grosjean habite à cinq minutes de
la colline et depuis qu'il est à la
retraite il vient à presque tous les
jours donner un coup de main aux
clarisses
j'aime bien le lieu ici ça respire la
paix la sérénité le calme je suis
impliqué quand même dans la vie
religieuse depuis une plus jeune enfance
puis les clarisses et une communauté
même qu'il faut vider
donc je remette un peu peut-être parce
qu'ils manquent de
vous taper dedans pour m
merci alors légende ronchamp départ
était vraiment
très dubitatif quant à notre présence il
avait fait des expériences ap délicate
avec d'autres communautés religieuses
qui est arrivé avec leur spiritualité
enquête sous le bras nous nous sommes
arrivés aux petites franciscaines en
disant on vient prier ou bien on est là
et ce qu'ils pensent nous a servi c'est
d'avoir vécu pendant 23 mois à l'abri du
pèlerin dans des conditions spartiates
et puisque spartiate et du coup les gens
n'auraient de ronchamp même ce sont dix
ans à sepa confort matériel c'est pas le
confort spirituel qu'elle recherche
elles viennent pour autre chose et
progressivement comme ça des liens se
sont creusées et là on voit bien le
dimanche il ya quand même des gens
brochand et des environs qui vient de
célébrer avec nous la journée des soeurs
et rythmée par les quatre temps de
prière et le travail les clarisses se
sont spécialisés dans les vêtements
liturgiques avec l'arrivée en janvier
2016 de la soeur anglaise marie thérèse
les broderies sont maintenant réalisées
via un ordinateur un travail que les
visiteurs de la colline aperçoive lorsqu
ils longent le monastère la présence là
des soeurs elle est manifeste bien sûr
il ya les bâtiments et puis il ya tout
ce qui se passe entre la chapelle et
l'oratoire est alors pour moi qui ai
vécu des situations un peu loufoque là
je dirais qu'il ya 30 ou 40 ans et
comportements de visiteurs qui étaient
complètement
irresponsable qui courait dans la
chapelle qui grimpaient partout ça a
disparu
le moment où l'on voit le plus les
soeurs c'est quand elle prit en présence
du public de passage et puis il ya aussi
les amis des soeurs qui viennent tout
spécialement la chapelle comme angélique
adolphe
a beaucoup changé parce que ça m'a donné
de plus envie de venir prier ici qui
sait il ce concept c'est une simplicité
et puis on voit qu'ils ont donné leur
vie par amour pour le seigneur et
moissac y est je vous le dis france à ça
vraiment changé ma vie d'avoir les
soeurs ici chaleureuse
on pourrait penser que les touristes
soient gênés par cette présence
religieuse mais en fait pas vraiment ils
sont indifférents intrigué même
intéressé
nous sommes venus principalement pour l'
architecture mais avec les soeurs c'est
mieux nous serions venus signer veut pas
eu de liturgie mais comme il y en avait
une cela a rendu la visite plus
intéressante s'est trouvé là au bon
moment nous on a pris ça comme une
immense voilà une opportune je suis
pratiquant donc on s'est dit et je
n'osais pas imposer à mon ami là mais
c'est quand elle m'a dit bien on reste
jéhovah oui oui pour être franche on ne
vient pas que pour l'architecte des
ronds vient ici pour l'énergie du lieu
pour la spiritualité pour les
pratiquantes ou pas n'a pas de là ça n'a
pas d'importance
les soeurs ne sont pas à l'abri des
regards enfermé par des murs de trois
mètres comme elles ont pu le vivre dans
leur jeunesse le monastère n'a pas de
clôtures et c'est voulu c'est plus
facile aux
vivre cachés derrière nous tous peuvent
être que vous devez tous les faits mais
ici il y avait personne partout tout le
temps que le site et huw est jeune et il
peut être ce jeune homme est et je pense
et c'est très important que aujourd'hui
des crises étaient visibles que il n'y a
rien caché de
jowood des autres qu' il n'y a pas de
secret
et cette transparence les survols
exprimé aussi dans leur prise de parole
franche et sans détour